am i that was actually going to be one
of my questions if you're withholding
sex can you be mad if he cheats
hell no hell no
yes and no okay why because i feel like
if a woman is going to put herself in
that position
expect the worst she understands because
you've now decided to withhold your
withhold your sexual interaction with
your partner but
me i did not come and force you to go
and do x y and z and step out on your
relationship or your marriage a man
needs to also have a level of
accountability yeah i could have been
the catalyst i could have been what i've
pushed you in that direction but also if
you love your misses you would sit down
and have a serious convo with that
there's a risk that's that that's not
true though because i feel like no no
but it's not because sex because again
sex is different for men and for women
i've heard guys say on my show that you
know she was better than my hand
and that's that's yeah like
why are you guys why are you guys
laughing why are you guys laughing
because they understand
and so and so it's like a guy it's just
like an instinct and maybe in his head
he loves his wife but if it doesn't if
she doesn't know it doesn't hurt her
and it has any and he knows deep down
like it has nothing to do with her i'm
not saying it's okay
but it's kind of like a lot of girls
will put their husbands in that
situation yeah like even if you don't
have even if you don't want to have sex
like your mouth can do something yeah
it's the catalyst because you're foolish
if you're gonna do that as a woman one
thing i'd like to add though is that
reason why they cheat and keep it secret
is due to the fact that if the
relationship's going downhill she's
withholding sex but if they're married
he's got a lot to lose if he just says
yeah i'm walking out now but there goes
half your money there goes maybe your
kid's not being seen there goes a big
fallout between you and this lady and
now you're gonna suffer so if you just
do it on the slide get yourself some
extra curricular panani basically
they're doing it on the slide due to the
fact that repercussions of telling you
might even be more severe you see i
didn't consider that but that's actually
kind of true so you want to
hit the road
well it's not necessarily they want
their cake and eaten too it's just the
consequences for divorce is a lot higher
for men so in the u.s it's if a man gets
divorced and he has let's say two kids
by the woman his he loses 25
per child after taxes so your
discretionary income
and he owes that girl child support for
18 years exactly so so imagine imagine
you know make taking home 2 000 a month
and you have to give 1 000 a month to
your ex-wife for existing for 18 years
and so when you're thinking about
cheating right and like now you're in a
sexless marriage
and maybe it's been a year maybe it's
been two years like it's
you could say hey i'm gonna cheat if you
don't give me sex but then she could
divorce your ass
so it's kind of like damned if you do
damned if you don't exactly you know the
concept of a rock
i feel like a man would know that is
like that is the potential thing that
could happen well well i i don't i don't
think most men know that they're going
to be in sexless marriages
i think that comes later
yeah you can't predict that but i'm
saying if i'm like if a man goes out and
cheats and
knows that his
that this could be the potential
backlash from your wife that she will
leave you and whatever it may be you
know that that's a risk that you've
taken
right he does know it's at risk yeah but
it's like the other risk is to demand
sex from his wife and then he could lose
half his [ __ ] so from a guy's point of
view if there's just one random girl
that is never gonna find his wife and
it's a one-time thing he doesn't care
about her he just hasn't had sex in a
year
and then like to them
it's just like the risk the reward
outweighs the risk because he doesn't
think she'll find out
to be honest i would say that you're
definitely right in that respect however
and not to kind of you know crap on men
so to speak because i
can completely understand from you know
those circumstances but i would say it's
always best to just encourage people to
do the right thing anyway if you really
really had a problem you know with your
wife and discussions weren't working it
would probably be better for you to
maybe discuss taking a break maybe even
split up now granted the woman's um
behavior in this scenario was she kind
of set up the
you know the whole kind of chain of
events that was following and makes her
man you know want to leave but
just being the voice of reason we just
got encouragements to do the right see
and i do i don't agree with cheating but
i just
i'm thinking
i'm stupid
i'm cheap okay i really i don't like
spending money why do i send money get
issue camera
um
but but like i'm thinking if i if i had
the option of this conversation but i
know if she has this com like me because
he knows his wife right he knows that
she's probably going to leave if he says
this to her so i'm thinking 50 of my
income for 18 years after taxes
that's so much money
that's the number one way nba players go
broke is they get the wrong girl
pregnant so i can ask you a question so
in american law does it always default
the kids to the mother or is there kind
of like an investigative competency
the mom has to the courts are heavily
skewed against men yeah so
the mom has to like f it up big time in
order for to get to to not have
the kids so i want to say it's 80 of the
time
that she wins yeah it's pretty much the
same in the uk as well bro kind of rough
unfortunately i believe it yeah and
child support here is around 20
or 18 i think 18
so it's not it's not as crazy as the us
the u.s laws but it's still enough that
i've seen a lot of judge judy i know
but and that's and that's why you see
girls stealing nba players condoms
they're because
yeah that was actually kind of
outrageous because they're they're
incent the way the laws are now it's
it's incentivizing women to get a kid
off of a rich guy
because even even i think here it's
16 percent or 19 something let's go with
16 though if a guy's making 200 000 a
year that's still a big that's a that's
a whole income for me it is that's
that's wage i think it goes to 25 if
they got multiple kids so if they get
two it can go up to 25 percent
in the uk
check me on that chat or whatever else
that's the relevant details but i
believe so
wow and so it kind of that's why it goes
back to his sex of duty and then
and it's hard because i and the way i
think is there any way you could legally
protect that but i don't think you could
right
yeah and so it begs the question should
the courts even should the government
even be in marriage to begin with
exactly i think they should okay why the
reason why i think they should is
because the idea of let's say marriage
is not something that
like let's say for example when you look
at things like let's say faith and
religion you have a lot of people that
will talk about things like sanctity of
marriage and you know the government
shouldn't be involved however i'm of the
firm opinion that matt the concept of
marriage is not exclusive to religion in
fact i would argue in many places across
the world before religion even becomes a
thing
there is um concepts and ideas of you
know of marriage
and
you know if we're gonna say for example
live in a free society you know in in
you know in a world where you want your
spouse to have control over things like
if you're on your deathbed do they turn
off the life support or keep it on you
need that to be kind of recognized and
legalized you see what i'm saying
so